Now that you're familiar with graphing
horizontal and vertical lines,
I want you to practice
graphing your own.
And now I can't have you draw
on your computer screen, so
we're going to try something else.
I want you to get a sheet of graph
paper, or you can print one out or
make your own, and I'm going to give
you the equation for four lines.
I'm going to ask you to graph them.
Now let's say the four lines I gave you
wound up looking something like this.
You can see that they enclose
this rectangle here, and
in that rectangle there are 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12 squares, these four lines enclose
a rectangle that has 12 squares.
Now, I'm going to give you the equation
of four different lines and
ask you to graph those yourself and
then count up the number of
squares inside those four lines.
So what I want to know is how many
squares are inside the rectangle
formed by these four lines?
And the equations are here, and you can
enter the number of squares in this box.
Now I really recommend you get a sheet
of graph paper, do this yourself, and
count up the squares.
The practice is really useful.